[Musique]
et le festival de cannes ce n'est pas
que des oeuvres en compétition au sein
du palais environ 12 mille
professionnels du cinéma se retrouvent
chaque année au marché du film parmi une
réalisatrice de 27 ans et qui est
originaire de chevreuse jenna sur rue
après des cours de comédie et de théâtre
à paris à londres et los angeles
elle vient à cannes pour vendre son long
métrage il s'appelle l'âge d'or
[Musique]
bienvenue dans le paris los angeles et
san tropez des années 60 l'âge d'or
c'est l'histoire d'une rencontre qui va
changer le monde
entre un producteur est une actrice un
film tourné dans plus de 35 lieux
hommage aux artistes de l'époque des
beatles à brigitte bardot en passant par
françois truffaut des artistes qui
venaient des quatre coins du monde non
seulement français mais également en
anglais américains et qu'ils se
rendaient notamment dans ce petit
village à l'époque qui était un petit
port de pêcheurs maintenant devenu grand
saint tropez et donc c'est la bague on
trouve l'inspiration ils ont vraiment
réussi à changer ce monde qui marchait
sur la tête jeune réalisatrice de 27 ans
jena est à cannes pour distribuer son
film en france et à l'international au
sein du pavillon de l'europe la
chevrotine rencontre également des
directeurs de festivals pour la
promotion du long-métrage
l'âge d'or vient tout juste d'être
terminée et a été projeté au marché du
film et rendez vous c'est surtout les
directeurs de festivals et pas seulement
français armand en europe en asie en
afrique dans les amériques vraiment dans
le monde entier les premiers rendez-vous
ont été extrêmement positifs les
premiers retours sur la projection sont
extrêmement positifs
donc on est vraiment très optimiste et
très fiers et c'est que le début parce
que je suis donc il sait jusqu'à la fin
du marché du festival de cannes le
marché du film se clôturera le 23 mai
deux jours avant la fin du festival de
cannes
en gros j'ai l'impression qu'à moitié du
temps
tout va mal
et l'autre moitié du temps est filmé
dame
tu as déjà de la chance la moitié du
temps c'est formidable
[Musique]
à partir de ce soir et jusqu'à jeudi on
retrouve depuis cannes
hugo casadamont en partenariat avec
radio sensations découverte avec lui de
la réalisatrice cécile ya deux ans pour
son film mardi de huit à dix huit
sélectionnés à cannes
un vent de jeunesse sur la croisette
avec cécilia de ars jeune réalisatrice
et scénariste diplômés des troisièmes
l'institut international de l'image et
du son
deux trappes avec son premier court
métrage produit mardi de 8 à 18 qui a
été sélectionné à la 58e semaine de la
critique
l'une des sélections parallèles du
festival de cannes elle n'en revient
toujours pas je vous propose qu'on l'ait
coûte tout de suite et juste après on
découvre un extrait de son film je suis
vraiment très contente d'être ici en
plus la semaine de la critique c'est
quand même une sélection formidable les
gens sont super gentils
je suis hyper heureuse de venir
présenter ce film en plus que j'ai fait
avec une équipe vraiment merveilleuse
logan logan une chance mais j'ai le mal
d'excusés dans le casier me demanderez
ce film parle de les métiers de pions du
métier de surveillant
c'est l'histoire d'une surveillante qui
fait son mieux auprès des élèves qui se
démène avec
dans un collège et qui va faire une
erreur idiote va donner une casquette
des objets trouvés à un élève l acquis
cette casquette comme ça je peux la
rolls je te dis non bosse à la personne
peut la prendre et ça va entraîner des
conséquences gravissimes enfin une
bagarre l'exclusion de l'enfance a en
tout cas une risque d'exclusion donc
voilà le sujet dans l'histoire du film
c'est celle là l'est sujet du film après
je voulais vraiment parlait déjà du
métier des idées que je trouve un nombre
de surveillants que je trouve hyper
intéressant en fait c'est une espèce des
postes un peu hybride
on est à la fois on n'a pas beaucoup de
responsabilités une concrète en tout cas
pas beaucoup de reconnaissance parce
qu'on est considéré entre les adultes et
les enfants on est vraiment dans un
poste où voilà on n'a pas de formation
pour travailler dans l'éducation
nationale c'est vraiment considéré comme
un petit boulot c'est quoi ça demande
plus à de ma faute c'est moi qui t'ai
donné la casquette je le sais pas où est
cette info mais non mais si tu veux je
leur dis moi je m'en fous on va voir la
proviseure tous les deux le film laborde
légèrement mais en tout cas parler de
l'autorité de des rapports de hiérarchie
avec les enfants justement et enfin deux
mesures c'est bien ou pas d'intégrer
cinq ans dans l'éducation voilà c'était
un peu faire un petit panorama d'un
collège un peu normal je sais pas si ça
marchera mais en tout cas j'avais envie
de montrer que la vie
et puis chaque soir focus sur un film
soutenu par la région ile de france
présenté à cannes sybille réalisé par
justin triais il fait partie des 21
films en compétition officielle
sybille est une romancière reconversion
psychanalyste et alors que son envie
d'écrire revient une jeune comédienne la
supplie de la recevoir en plein tournage
elle est enceinte de l'acteur principal
qui est en couple avec la réalisatrice
du film
[Musique]